war for the Planet of the Apes is
directed by Matt Reeves who also made
the last one and this one stars Andy
Serkis once again as Caesar we've seen
the Apes rise to take over humankind and
we've seen a dawn of a new era in which
the Apes are ruling over the earth and
now we are going to see a war between
the last remaining humans and the vastly
intelligent Apes this has been a great
series so far I love drys I loved dawn
and whenever we get to the third entry
in a proposed trilogy I get nervous
because most of the time the third
entries aren't as good it's very rare
very very rare that the third entry and
a trilogy is the best I saw this movie a
few days ago and I went home and I
thought about it before I turn on the
camera because I wanted to make sure
that I was feeling the way I was really
feeling
I watched rise again because I hadn't
seen it in many years and I watched dawn
again and I do feel that war for the
Planet of the Apes joins movies like
Lord of the Rings Return of the King or
The Bourne Ultimatum as being the best
in the trilogy that's so rare and this
movie floored me I think it's a
masterpiece I've thought a lot about
this and I honestly can't find a scene a
moment a line of dialogue even that
feels out of place there is one
exposition seen in this movie one that
was one of the few issues I had with
Dawn was that there was just a lot of
expositional dialogue they have wiped
that out almost entirely there's one
sequence between Caesar and Woody
Harrelson's character where they discuss
the past and certain things that have
happened to those characters and beyond
that this is a bleak and brutal
uncompromising movie that had me riveted
from the opening scene to the final one
I loved every minute of this movie it's
jaw-dropping the motion capture work
it's real i watch this movie and almost
every frame just had me gripped to my
seat just because I was looking at
something that I knew was created by a
team of incredible professionals who
have an insane amount of talent
and it tape off this is easily the best
motion caption work I have ever seen an
Andy Serkis once again as usual is
brilliant as Caesar but it must not go
overlooked the team of people who
actually worked on the effects the
animators my god these people are
geniuses one of my favorite characters
and all three of these movies is more
Easter orangutan so great once again
here and again amazing performances
pretty much my main issue with these
films at least before this one was that
the human characters were never as
interesting as the Apes whenever they
would cut back to James Franco's
character or Frieda pintos character or
Jason Clarke Keri Russell I was like and
I can we just get back to Caesar because
that's kind of like where the heart of
the movie is war for the Planet of the
Apes is almost exclusively about the
Apes
Woody Harrelson runs a faction of men
who are enslaving some Apes and sort of
a death camp very Holocaust like
scenario there's a lot of Holocaust
imagery in this movie but for the most
part we are exclusively following Caesar
on a trail of revenge and the
construction of this movie is staggering
what you learn in just the opening scene
like the first few minutes of the movie
basically set up everything you need to
know about the film and it connects back
perfectly to the finale and if you re
watch all three of them in a row you're
going to see a huge overarching story
that really works as a whole and that's
what the best trilogies do it's not just
a great film it's a great addition to
the other two when you watch Rise and
Dawn and then war all in a row it's
going to feel natural I could not be
happier with this movie Matt Reeves
directed this film so beautifully the
cinematography the editing it's all
seamless Michael Giacchino has made one
of his best scores and the music plays a
large part in this movie because there
are a lot of sequences of tear silence
where Caesar will be like signing to
another ape and than the ape will be
signing back and all you really have is
their performances the timing of the
shots and that music and there are also
very important moments that set up
Caesars path of revenge told entirely
silent with just music and performance
and it's the definition of epic there
are so many sequences in this movie that
made my jaw drop
just from a filmmaking perspective it's
also highly unconventional when I went
into this movie I was expecting one
thing a gigantic action scene and you
get that but not in the way you might
think
and I of course will not ruin it for you
but the film sets up certain beats in
the first act and your brain starts to
work as someone who watches a lot of
movies and you think I know exactly
where this is going to go da da da da da
da I've got it all figured out in my
head and the film doesn't do that it
doesn't give its characters the easy way
out
it makes them have hard choices and
difficult decisions and you get to watch
the progression of Cesar's character and
going from this small chimpanzee in the
first film to a hardened leader and to
now someone who's struggling with the
darker side of himself and it's
completely riveting from beginning to
end as I said it barely feels like
there's a moment wasted there's a great
storyline with a young girl that I
thought was really sweet Steve Zahn as
bad ape that's where the film could have
gone wrong because he's kind of a
comedic relief character in a very dark
film but I thought he worked great he
was a risk that paid off because trust
me whenever a movie is this good you're
going to see all those articles like you
know top ten reasons you need to know
right now that war for the Planet of the
Apes took no risks top ten you need to
know red circle red arrow click this the
character of bad ape is a major risk he
really could have tanked many scenes in
this movie but they found the exact
right level of emotion to have him on
and I thought he was a great strength to
the film I don't really want to get into
aspects of the plot I'm just going to
talk entirely about the filmmaking in
this review because I didn't watch a
single trailer for this movie and I'm
really glad I didn't because I knew
nothing and going in blind it was a
beautiful experience I'm going to give
war for the Planet of the Apes and A+
I think this is one of the best
trilogies of all time and it also serves
as a good reminder that prequels can
sometimes be pretty good guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]